evènement dans le domaine des variétés à
la sochaux chante ce soir pour la
première fois de sa carrière au palais
des sports il ne s'était pas produit à
paris depuis deux ans et demi dominique
poncet l'a rencontré au cours de l'une
de ses toutes dernières répétitions
quelques fois j'ai dit que j'étais pas
assez intelligent ça veut pas dire que
je me trouve con ça veut dire que
j'aimerais être hyper intelligent
j'adore ça l'intelligence même s'ils
continuent à n'être jamais content
depuis 12 ans maintenant il ya du soufre
dans l'air mais ferdinand qui y vivaient
plus appartient plus sa demande de
boulot c'est peut-être ça la foutrait
l'élégant sochalienne on avance on
avance en les croire qu'on a toujours
vivant tia écrire les chansons c'est à
dire est seul avec la page blanche c'est
prétentieux grand dealer com dire que ça
fait peur mais quand y'a rien il faut
qu'il y ait quelque chose ça fait peur
et c'est frémissant et c'est formidable
après face à ce conflit
et puis là au palais des sports de gens
les gens contre la page blanche puis le
jean il ya toutes les mises et un truc
c'est les deux mouvements principaux de
ma vie je n'aime pas les nier du tout
d'avoir 40 ans alors ça m'a vachement
l'univers entends tu peux juste la
résonance ou 30 31 32 sérieuse concerne
le grand vieux adultes 20 40 60 foutu
alors puis 30 foutu cauchemar quand vous
ne chantez pas quand vous n'écrivez pas
quand vous jouez pas qu'est ce que vous
faites
qu'est ce que vous préférez faire j'aime
bien marcher dans la campagne
vingt-six enfants
tu sais je vois bien je prends la tâche
à chanter l'amour sur utah
oui je comprends que jusque j'ai chanté
deux gars tous les hommes étaient
fragiles par as un peu fragile
vous voulez tous les hommes on a envie
hein par moment d'être maternelle et
fonctionnel c'est fragile mais on n'est
pas que ça moi je suis comme tous les
hommes